pues estuvo en ese así esto es a 30
kilómetros al noroeste de parís
efectivamente al tercer día no resucitó
pero sí reapareció el presidente en
medio de un montón de personas en el
mercado de esta de esta pequeña ciudad
una ciudad que votó el 76 por ciento por
él en esta segunda vuelta pero que en la
primera había votado mayoritariamente
por el melón so en todo caso pues allí
fue recibido al un poco por aplausos
pero también algunos abucheos en lo que
dijo es que lo que quería hacer es
seguir estando ahí junto a los franceses
junto a las francesas tal y como lo
había hecho en la campaña pues que su
nuevo mandato iba a hacer eso se puede
hacer quizás ese nuevo método del que
nos había hablado el pasado domingo en
su discurso en la torre eiffel cuando él
hablaba precisamente una idea de
reinvención en todo caso estuvo allí
diciendo que es una ciudad donde tiene
pues que tiene bastantes problemas
sociales bastante problemas económicos
especialmente en la juventud y que él
estaba haciendo allí más que acto de
presencia ese entendiendo y queriendo
escuchar también lo que dicen los
franceses en medio de toda esa
multitud que estaba ahí a rodeándolo le
lanzaron unos tomates pero el el
presidente se mostró imperturbable
continuó su visita como si no hubiera
pasado nada y se tomó todo el tiempo
para hablar con cada una de estas
personas así que así en este lugar es
que reapareció emanuel mccone que sabe
que tiene que convencer a este
electorado de izquierda también para las
legislativas también la prensa tuvo la
ocasión de preguntarle quién iba a ser
ese primer ministro y simplemente dijo
que era alguien que tuviera que fuera
muy sensible a la ecología